a blaze out of control and with no end
in sight Canada's Alberta province is
seeing unprecedented wildfires and they
are spreading closer to roads
complicating efforts to contain them a
major highway was closed on Tuesday
there are 71 wildfires in the forest
protection area of Alberta 20 of those
are out of control
so far this year we've responded to 520
wildfires burning more than one million
000 hectares
last year that number was 2200 times
lower less than 500 hectares
almost 3 000 firefighters are already in
Alberta half of them from the United
States more help arrives later this week
from Australia and New Zealand and the
weather is expected to finally lend a
helping hand some much-needed rain
Alberta is starting to see some cooler
temperatures and Scattered precipitation
helping to provide some relief to
firefighters we're hoping the weather
continues to assist in the fight against
wildfires more than 10 000 people have
been forced to leave their homes smoke
continues to cause poor air quality and
reduce visibility Canada's environment
agency says people in affected areas
should stay indoors or wear respirator
masks dimitrium advidenko Al Jazeera
the Spanish Football Federation